it's deeply painful to face what's
happening on our planet right now from
forest burning ocean plastic species
just gone each day displacement it's
easy to feel totally overwhelmed maybe a
bit helpless powerless angry on fire
numb disconnected perhaps all of the
above these messy and complicated
feelings they make total sense I wish
that someone had said this to me thirty
years ago I was a college freshman
taking Environmental Studies which is
basically a semester of really bad news
about all the ways that humans have
profoundly damaged our beautiful earth
and I felt like I had been dropped into
a dark tunnel given no tools to get out
and yet expected to carry on with my
everyday life as if things were normal
but once you're exposed to that kind of
information things are not normal
anymore and I was anxious I was
terrified no one was talking about this
and I almost dropped out of school for
real but instead I signed up for a field
study in California and we were
backpacking together as a small group
for two months which I know sounds very
intense and it was but what I found is
that we talked a lot we talked about how
we were feeling about the world openly
and honestly and no one told me at any
point to be more positive
Orma hopeful not once and surprisingly I
found myself feeling better I actually
felt like I could face these issues that
had seemed so insurmountable more
head-on and I had this epiphany what if
by understanding ourselves and one
another we could find our way through
this crisis in a new and different way
you know what if psychology actually
held a missing key to unlocking action
on the greatest challenges facing our
planet right now so when I got back from
the field study I focused on clinical
psychology and I research the
relationships between trauma and grief
and creativity and the paradox at the
heart of I think all of this which is
how do we stay present with what's
really painful how do we stay connected
in the face of what's threatening and
overwhelming and scary and it turns out
that psychology knows a lot about these
things truly a lot but I wasn't hearing
any of this being referenced in my
environmental studies class or the
climate action meetings I started going
to or the international conferences
where everyone's asking why aren't we
acting faster and what's it going to
take and so this has become my mission
of sorts which is that I take insights
from psychology and I translate them
into resources and tools to support
those working on the frontlines to turn
things around and that means for anyone
by the way we're all on the front lines
right now and it's my belief after years
of straddling these worlds between
environment and climate and psychology
that this actually is a missing
ingredient in our work that can
exponentially accelerate our capacities
to be creative and resilient and capable
and skillful and courageous and all
those things that the world is needing
from us right now so I'm going to share
three concepts with you that I found
petechiae
game changing and how I make sense of
this moment for us as humans and the
first is something called our window of
Tolerance
so dr. dan Siegel has described us all
as having a window how much stress can
we tolerate while staying connected and
what clinicians would call integrated
integrated where we can actually be in
touch with our thoughts and feelings and
not just get kind of co-opted and we all
have a threshold and what happens when
we experience stress beyond what we can
tolerate we tend to go into the edges of
our window and on one hand we might go
into a sort of a collapse that chaotic
what's called a chaotic response which
looks like depression despair kind of a
shutting down and on the other side of
this window is a more rigid response
denial anger rigid and so when that
happens we actually lose our capacity to
be integrated resilient adaptive all
those things that we want to be and this
is totally normal but it's happening all
around the world right now right we're
all vacillating between these different
feelings and emotions and so with
something like climate change with every
new scientific report documentary
connecting the dots between you know
what we're doing and the impact it's
having it can collectively be pushing us
outside of our window of Tolerance and
we lose that capacity right so over the
years I've interviewed hundreds of
people from all backgrounds and
political affiliations from the Midwest
us to China and I talked to people about
how are we feeling about what's
happening not what opinions or beliefs
what are we feeling about what's going
on with your local environment with your
water your soil the big picture and what
I hear from people almost across the
board I'm telling you is a binds people
tell me at some point in the
conversation I care very deeply about
what's happening I'm
incredibly freaked out I'm scared I love
this land I love the birds whatever that
is but I feel like my actions are
insignificant and I don't know where to
start and I'm also I hear between the
lines of what people say I'm really
scared to change really scared of any
changes so I can't even think about it
it's like unthinkable and this is the
second concept which is something called
a double bind and a double bind is when
we feel sort of like damned if you do
and damned if you don't and you're just
kind of stuck there it's a very
intolerable human experience and we will
do anything we can to get rid of it and
just push it away and so all that care
and concern it's there it just goes down
it goes underground but what happens is
it looks like people don't care looks
like apathy and so a lot of folks who
are seeing the urgency of the situation
are like we got a motivate you we got to
get you psyched and we become
cheerleaders for solutions or like
here's the fact this is happening wake
up and these things are actually not
inherently bad because we need solutions
and we need to face the facts but
inadvertently this can backfire and lead
to more numbing and inaction which is
very perplexing for a lot of people it's
like what the heck is going on right and
so this is this is because of this you
know it's not really touching what's
going on underneath so imagine that you
go see a therapist and you've got a
double bind you're feeling really stuck
you know you got to change and the
therapist starts shouting at you and
saying don't you see what's happening if
you don't act now you're gonna face
terrifying consequences don't you care
what's wrong with you what's it gonna
take or you see a therapist and you're
feeling actually sad and
grief and this therapist says you know
don't think about it too much
here's some simple things you can do
simple positive things and sends you on
your way so if it were me I would fire
this therapist immediately because a
good therapist practices something
called a tune mint I love this concept
so much a two mints write the word two
tune and a two mints is when we're
feeling in sync when we feel understood
and we feel accepted for exactly where
we are and we feel that you know we're
in relationship with the world in a way
that makes sense no one's trying to
change us or shame us or judge us right
and attunement takes skill when the
stakes are high let me tell you it's
very hard to want to attune with
anything when we're facing such urgent
threats but the paradox of the moment
we're in is that when we are more in
tune in their window of Tolerance we are
so much more capable of solving problems
being creative being adaptive being
flexible being our brilliant selves
right so what if our climate and
environmental work was informed by these
concepts right of window of Tolerance a
lot of double binds and attunements so
it can look like a whole lot of things
so I'm asked all the time okay Renee
this sounds awesome for clinical context
we don't have time for this and that is
absolutely not true
because we can bring attunement into
every aspect of our work on this issue
and it starts with ourselves you
actually can't do a two minute unless
you're in touch with yourself I'm sorry
to break it to you there's no way around
it it's from the inside out and so it
starts with actually tuning into how my
feeling and being
passionate I know it's easy to say but
really being compassionate like these
are hard issues this is a hard moment to
be a human being we're waking up I'm not
a bad person what's going on Breen
curiosity into our own experience which
then allows us to attune socially that's
the the next way we can apply this is it
tuning whether it's in small groups or
one-on-one campaigning strategy
classrooms movie theaters parks where we
can give each other permission to just
be who we are and again this allows us
to move into the higher-level
functioning the executive function of
prefrontal cortex when we feel that our
nervous system can calm down and we are
understood by the other and the third
way is leading with attunements at the
leaders and influencers showing up as
human as real saying you know what like
I am really scared I don't know what all
the answers are can you imagine leaders
saying that I don't know but here we are
and we're all needed and we're in this
together and we can do this that's a
very different message than just we can
do this right it's like here we are I'm
scared but this is happening so here's
the thing is that all of this work
exists we have the tools to create these
conditions that can allow us to show up
as our brilliant selves and I know
without doubt 100% that each one of us
has the capacity to meet these
challenges with the ingenuity and
brilliance and bravery that we as humans
have we just need to cultivate the
conditions together we need each other
to support each other and allow
ourselves to really meet this that's
what we need so let's take a deep breath
have compassion for ourselves and one
another in this moment time in history
as we collectively process these painful
truths these difficult realities let's
do this together
the world is ready for us to do this and
we can do this thank you
[Applause]
[Music]